てめえら。男は何でモテるか知ってるか？
髪型？チッチッチッ
服？チッチッチッ
心？
・・・
それは大事
俺はね、最近肌を気にしてるんすよ。お肌
お肌がな、夏は荒れるんすよ。
汗かくし日焼けするしで
もうね、オハンディングがね、大変なことになってね
非常にねまずいんすよ
メンズもね、お肌のケア大事にしてかなきゃいけない時代に入ってきてるんで
俺は、お肌大事にしたいと思って今日は宅急便を頼んだわけですよ。
待って本名書いてある
なんか僕宛てにね、なんかこう、
いろいろ書き込んでから届くんすよ。
今回はですね、ドモホルンリンクルを買ってみました。
知ってるでしょドモホルンリンクル。
「ドモホルンリンクルは初めてのお客様には販売することが出来ません」
初めてお客様なんで販売されなかったんすよ。
ネットで書き込んで「お肌はどうですか」とかこういろんなアンケートを受けて
俺に合った化粧品がちゃんと届くわけです。
ドモホルンリンクルのお試しセットを今日買ってみたわけなんで
実際にねドモホルンリンクルを使って
俺のお肌きれいにしよう生活の幕開けです今日は
「開封して中の情報をどうぞご覧ください」
めっちゃ入ってるんすよ。
一通りなんかいろんなあれが入ってます。
あの、化粧落としジェル、洗顔(石鹸）
泡の集中パック、保湿液、美白エキス、保湿クリーム、保護乳液、日焼け止め。
あ、無料です。
無料でもらえたんですけど、
すまねえなちょっと完全に個人的な動画だわ今日は
「どうして私たちのお肌は20歳のままではいれられないのでしょうか」
そうだ、お肌っつうのはね、20歳から
くうに
急に来るんすよ。
これちゃんと全部使って初めて効果があるみたいな感じっぽいですね。
取り敢えず、お試しなんでどんな感じなのかっていうのがまあ分かればいいなって感じっす
早速ドモホルンリンクルやってみますか！
ちゃんと番号が振ってあってとても分かりやすい。
まずはこちらの化粧落としジェルでお肌の化粧を落としていこうと思います。
僕化粧はしないんでジェルを塗った所で考えます。
まずはこれでしっかりお肌の・・・
えっと
ジェルを落としましょう(?)
違う、お肌の化粧を落としましょう。
しっかり化粧を落とすことが大事だと思います。
しっかり化粧を落としてからやりましょうね。
ジェルがオイル状・・・
あ、待って、オイル状にしなきゃ駄目だったんだ！
やべお肌に負担をかけた！
俺いきなりミスったわ
洗顔石鹸
こちらの洗顔石鹸をやっていこうと思います
俺は昔ニキビに悩んだからね。洗顔は大事ですよ。
わ、泡がすごいきめ細かい。
はい、洗い終わってきたんですけど、
泡たたなかったんだよあんまり
ドモホルンリンクルのあれはちょっとオイラの技術ではあわだだでることはできまs
次です3番目！
泡の集中パックつって
「もっちり濃厚な泡がダメージをみるみる解きほぐす
素肌が見えないくらいの厚さで目元口元ギリギリまで年齢の出やすい部分をしっかりほぐしていきます」
集中パックなんで泡ですね。
素肌が見えないくらいの厚さで
多くね
顔中を泡で覆う感じだと思います。
なるほどなるほど
これ大丈夫かな・・・
これホントに・・・ドモホルンリンクルってこんなの？
ちょっと出し過ぎちゃったな・・・
週に2回すればいいんだ！
俺これ多分1年分ぐらいやっちゃったよ多分
ビタミン、ミネラル、アミノ酸などのエネルギーを素早く届けてくれますお肌に
くらい柔らかなお肌を作ってくれます。
・・・・・・
こんなので言われても説得力がないね
これはね、良かったよ。泡の集中パックはグッドです。
じゃあPart4
保湿液
うるおわせながらだけではなく
乾きがちな年齢肌から潤う力を引き出す」
叩き込むんすね
なるほど
保湿液
これをねお肌にねばんばんバチ込んでいきます
バチ込むことによって水分と尿素・・・
尿素も使ってんの！？
汚くね！？
これお肌になじませて
こうね、叩くんすよ。
こうね、叩くことによって、
保湿液が入るんすよ。
いよいよ次は
「お肌本来の活力を引き出す
根本美白」
こんなんです。
ああ～これはね、分かる
俺でも分かる
これ肌にね、染み通ってるわ
これね分かるよ
美味そうなんだよな
ぺっ
「目元口元などの年齢の出やすい所を念入りに」
ハリが出るんだ！
ハリと艶が出ます
じゃクリーム早速塗っていきます
これはまだある程度でいいと思います
・・・・・・・・・
あ優しく塗りこまないといけないのかやべぇ
優しく塗りこんで白い所が無くなるまでやってください
あ、あとは二ついよいよ
保護乳液を塗っていきましょう
これ面倒くせーな
あ、これは普通の乳液です
しっかりね。
あ、こすっちゃダメなんだ！
手のひらでおさえ込んでいくらしい
なるほどなるほど
でこれはお顔だけではなく首筋や胸元とかにもね。
服だわ
肌にハリが出てきた
ここまでが基本要点です
ラストですね。
日中ケア光対策素肌ドレスクリームつってね
これが多分日焼け止めチックな感じです
「光の乱反射を抑え自然な素肌美が引き出されます」
なるほど
これを塗ることでばっちり日焼け止め対策ができるって事です
オッケー
これでいいのかな？
多分これで完璧だと思います
そうですね、ドモホルンリンクル的な考えでは多分ここまでで完璧です。
全部やるとまあ、こんな感じのお肌に仕上がってですね非常にハリがあるお肌になると思います。
日焼けもしないしお肌もきれいで完璧な状態で、
街に行けるということでね。
これでじゃあちょっとね、遊びに行っていこうと思います。
白い！！！